you were watching ColdFusion TV
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
at the end of last year I made a video
about five new technologies which most
people didn't expect to exist the
episode included an AI as I could look
at a static image and dream up a video
of what it thought would happen in the
next few seconds yes
it created a video from a still image I
went on to describe another AI that
could guess what's happening on the
scene just by listening to the audio it
was consistently better than humans at
doing this in the same video I talked
about yet another AI that can predict
human behavior was training only from
watching sitcoms if you haven't seen
this video yet you're missing out the
length of the video will be the first
one in the description today we'll be
looking at another interesting a I
imagine typing of descriptive sentence
of a theme and having an artificial
intelligence generate a convincing
photorealistic image just from your text
input this has just been created and
it's what we'll be taking a look at
today after this I'll share some of my
wider thoughts on artificial
intelligence let's get straight into it
[Music]
before we dive straight into the AI we
need to build a bit of context the type
of AI that we're about to look at is
called a neural network that's basically
a computing system that's modeled after
the human brain there are processing
nodes that act as neurons and the
neurons layers behave as segments of the
brain this concept an idea is nothing
new and it has been around since the
1980s but it's only become feasible in
the last five years due to GPUs with
hundreds of cores being cheap and
accessible in addition to this the
available open source tools for neural
networks are making it easier to create
pushing progress parabolically faster
so some examples of neural networks
include google's alphago and also things
like this an AI that's capable of
describing images in text form another
interesting example of neural networks
is wavenet an AI that can generate raw
sounds such as speech and music here are
some examples this first example is
speech generated by wavenet with a twist
wavenet wasn't specified what to say so
it had to make up its own language
notice the breathing and natural lip
sounds there the to deter suit now
ulcerative ruptured SIDS tell us guys
the langu he as the head she moved going
to officials apart yoga reverse share
dates to the dividend slow but we
couldn't retire set key a district in
Tata or V not a visitors crew rots for
life sis this next clip is some music
that wavelet generated again it wasn't
told what to play there was no musical
score it just played whatever it wanted
for this piece
wavenet was trained by listening to
classical music pieces
[Music]
so this is great but what if you want to
take things further what if we combine
two neural networks together and made
them compete against each other so that
they can train and improve themselves
without human intervention that's what
our featured AI called stack can is
doing it uses one neural network to
generate images and another neural
network within the same system to decide
if the image is generated a real or fake
what ends up happening is that the
generative neural network improves
itself at generating images based on the
feedback given by the deciding network
and in the same stride the deciding
network gets better at distinguishing
what's real and fake this creates a
feedback loop of continuous improvement
without human intervention the end
process this is a creation of a
low-resolution synthesized image after
this a second stage takes place in the
second stage the AI is told to clean up
any defects in the original picture and
the results are nothing short of
stunning yes what you're looking at our
image is created just by a written text
description
this type of dual network AI is called a
generative adversarial network and it's
the same type of system that allowed the
a I mentioned in my previous video to
dream up those videos when shown a still
image this form of artificial
intelligence is actually brand new and
was only invented in 2014 and already
I'm beginning to think that this is one
of the most powerful methods for machine
learning the text the image AI comes hot
on the heels of an artificial
intelligence from Carnegie Mellon
University beating the world's best
players of Texas Hold'em poker I
remember some people commenting on my
deep mine video and telling me that this
exact event was something that
artificial intelligence has been
struggling with for some time
there's also an AI that's been released
by gamilon a Boston company this one can
rewrite as own code based on experience
and probabilities rather than hard
variables its creators say that it could
make the tedious part of coding AI
completely automatic to give you an idea
how fast some areas of AI are
progressing here's a clip of Jeff Dean
athenaeus ello at google's research
group giving a presentation at a TED
talk to take an example the field with
computer vision every year there's a
contest where teams compete to see who
can give the right categories out of a
thousand different categories when given
an image and in 2011 before people were
using noir labs the winning team got an
error rate of 26% which doesn't sound
too good when you think that humans are
at 5% on this task but fast-forward five
just five years and we're now at 3%
errors using deep learning and much more
computational power
we're actually better than humans on
this task so in a way computers can now
see and recognize objects better than us
for the first time ever this has never
happened before in the same talk he goes
him to give an example of how unreliable
human ophthalmologists were for
diagnosing certain eye diseases
in experiments any two human
ophthalmologists will only agree with
each other's diagnosis 60% of the time
and what's worse if you give any single
ophthalmologist the exact same image
that they diagnosed a few hours earlier
they'll only agree with themselves 65
percent of the time in 2017 artificial
intelligence image recognition has been
proven to perform better than
professional humans in this field
as you see in this video things are
progressing fast and may have taken some
of you by surprise even the president of
alphabet sergey brin is being taken by
surprise by the entire phenomena of AI
in general AI effort but I didn't pay
attention to it at all to be perfectly
honest and you know myself having been
trained as a computer scientist in the
90s everybody knew AI didn't work it's
not like you know people tried it they
tried neural nets none of them worked
out yeah this kind of revolution in deep
net has been very profound and
definitely surprised me even though I
was like right in there it's an
incredible time and and it's very hard
to forecast you know what can these
things do we don't really know the
limits everything we can imagine and
more it's a hard thing to think through
and has really incredible possibilities
it seems like playtime is over in
regards to AI especially with techniques
like deep learning and neural networks I
think such things will cause social
discomfort as they begin to encroach
upon jobs
there's definitely both positives and
negatives to this phone but the question
is what does all of this mean and what
are we to do with all of these continual
shifts than what we thought was possible
in a general sense artificial
intelligence can be seen as a
continuation of the Industrial
Revolution happening over the past 200
years even right now artificial
intelligence is helping in the medical
field and making driving and other risky
tasks safer
Oh
let's just save my animation in the
future many mundane tasks can be handled
by AI giving more free time for people
to do creative things but of course and
I've heard this argument before not
everyone is creative life needs to have
meaning and for some individuals that
meaning comes in the form of their
day-to-day nine-to-five job I've been
thinking about making a video about
possible financial solutions to AI
disruption this includes concepts such
as universal basic income based on
blockchain technology and insights into
how some researchers are starting to
think about such things now of course
the some of you going to be thinking of
a Skynet scenario but right now it's
still far too early to predict
predicting the fully developed AI of the
future would be like trying to predict
today's computer industry from the point
of view of the 1960s personally I think
what we should actually be worried about
is who controls the AI if the strong
artificial intelligence of the future is
open source and available to everyone
there's a high probability that this
will be a good thing he's a small
example of an open-source AI having put
to good use a farmer in Japan used AI
computer vision and robotics to enable
his cucumbers to be automatically
selected and categorized saving him
hundreds of hours the artificial
intelligence driving his farm is called
tensorflow and it's open source and was
created by Google maybe in the future
instead of working for a company there
will be more common for people to run
their own businesses with their own
personal AI acting as a Productivity aid
so that's an example of open source a
are being used in a good way but
conversely if some of the best AI in the
world is held in the hands of a few the
probability of a good outcome overall
drops significantly in the latter case
it may be a case of whoever owns the AI
makes the rules to stop AI getting into
the wrong hands and to stop it becoming
dangerous
institutions such as the future of life
Institute have been set up it had tens
of millions of dollars in funding and
shows that people already thinking about
the next best steps for the future so
that's pretty much the end of this video
and I'm going to hand ball it to you
guys what do you think of the progress
being made by AI in the past few years
leave your thoughts in the comments
section below
anyway thanks for watching guys this
have been - go go you're been watching
cold fusion subscribe to this channel if
you just stumble across it don't forget
to check out my other video on the five
new technologies that you wouldn't think
to exist yet and of course I'll see you
again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]